bonjour didier billion merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
comment est ce que il faut interpréter
la sortie de ratchet tayyip erdogan
provocation moyens de pression
provocation je n'aime pas le terme parce
qu'il revient souvent quand on décrit la
politique extérieure de la turquie mais
il n'explique rien moyens de pression
oui très probablement nous savons que
les 6 à 10 ans le système des skates
sang a été déployé en turquie depuis le
mois de juillet 2019 les deux prix lors
il n'avait pas été activé ce qui était
assez paradoxal est intéressant mais
justement il ne l'avait pas été parce
que parce que erdogan le président turc
s'en servait comme moyen de pression sur
ses alliés occidentaux sur les états
unis sur l'otan en disant si vous n'avez
pas à mes revendications âme et exigeant
salorges activerait les missiles anti
missiles s-400 bien on en est arrivé là
c'est à dire que pour l'instant ils ne
sont pas véritablement opérationnel
certes mais il a été procédé à des
essais qui constitue un pas en avant
dans la mise en oeuvre de l'utilisation
potentielle de ces de ses systèmes
d'armement alors je crois que c'est à
mettre en rapport avec une sorte de
dégradation continue des relations de la
turquie avec les puissances occidentales
mais aussi peut-être ne pas l'oublier
nous savons que sur le terrain si rien
sur le terrain libyen que nous évoquions
précédemment
il y a eu des oppositions entre moscou
et ankara
mais pour autant et la turquie et la
russie sont arrivés à chaque fois à un
modus vivendi
or nous savons qu'il y ait un nouvel
élément du mat dans quelques semaines
c'est la question du haut karabagh et là
par contre les divergences entre moscou
et ankara sont beaucoup plus importantes
parce que moscou considère que le
caucase reste son arrière-cour et moscou
n'a nulle envie que ankara deviennent
trop influent dans cette partie du monde
le caucase et c'est peut-être donc pour
donner des gages à moscou que monsieur
erdogan a commencé à faire des essais
sur les 400 pour bien prouver qu'ils
n'avaient aucune velléité de s'opposer à
la russie dont
on a toujours un jeu à au moins trois
acteurs essentiels la russie la turquie
en l'occurrence et puis les alliés
occidentaux
je représente est symbolisée par l'otan
et justement on a vu un donc les
américains réagir critique est
évidemment ces tests mais comment vont
réagir les autres puissances vous venez
de parler de moscou est ce que la russie
va va s'exprimer
quid également des européens de paris ou
de londres moscou évidemment se félicite
promet le front très discrètement une
aucune raison à en rajouter mais c'est
un fait donc moscou se félicitera de la
proximité des points de vue et de la
coopération militaire avec avec la
turquie
je pense que l'union européenne va
traverser traditionnellement par ses
multiples prises de positions
différentes selon les états sera du
commentaire et ça c'est malheureusement
une habitude de l'union européenne alors
au sein de l'union européenne nous
savons parfaitement que sur ce dossier
dsk tu sens comme sur quelques autres
je pense notamment à la libye à la
méditerranée orientale à la cire et
cetera
il ya des états comme la france qui
seront beaucoup plus virulent à l'égard
de la turquie car nous savons qu'il ya
une dégradation permanente et et
inquiétante occupants des relations
entre la france et la turquie
d'autres états au contraire vont
peut-être amoindrir la portée de ses
effets et enfin autant les états unis
effectivement marqué leur désaccord et
leur colère devant ces essais de la part
de deux d'ankara encore je crois que
c'est une posture
le porte parole du département menace la
turquie de commentaires de deux mesures
de restrictions à l'égard de la
coopération en matière d'armement mais
c'est déjà fait on sait très bien que la
turquie était parti un programme de
coopération avec les états unis sur la
construction des chasseurs f 35 est que
ce programme de coopération est terminée
depuis justement que les 400 ont été
déployés sur le sol turc
il ya près d'un an et demi donc je ne
vois pas très bien ce que les américains
peuvent faire de plus les ce qui est
très simple
on sait que l'otan pour sa part en la
personne du secrétaire général de l'otan
se démerdent essaye toujours de
minimiser la portée des désaccords avec
la turquie parce que l'otan comprends
parfaitement que la turquie reste encore
un allié tout à fait indispensable et
air doit le comprendre qu'il joue sur
tous les tableaux se servant des
divergences qui est vise parmi ses
différents interlocuteurs gens se scinde
le temps pascal à les écouter pour
l'instant moi j'ai entendu à plusieurs
reprises qu'il était possible qu'ils
aient une rupture entre la turquie et
l'otan je n'y crois absolument pas à la
fois parce que comme je viens de
l'indiquer l'otan a toujours besoin de
la turquie
c'est à peu près le seul pays à peu près
stable de la région et nous ne
comprenons bien son rôle géostratégique
et puis par ailleurs même si les
relations sont souvent tendues avec
l'otan mais la turquie pour l'instant je
dis bien pour l'instant n'a nulle envie
partir de l'otan parce que l'otan
constitue encore à ce jour sa garantie
de sécurité principal ce n'est ni moscou
ni plus lointainement pékin qui puis lui
fournir à ce jeu à ce jour les choses
peuvent évoluer mais je ne crois pas
c'est pour l'immédiat qu'on puisse
imaginer
ddd rupture radicale dans les système
d'alliances concernant la turquie
merci didier billion d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le directeur adjoint de l'iris institut
des relations internationales et
stratégiques et vous êtes évidemment
spécialiste de la turquie on l'a bien
compris
merci à vous